Cuba is a baseball hotbed, but it's patchy
relationship with the United States has long
served as a stumbling block for Cubans hoping
to call Major League Baseball home.
This looks set to change after Cuba's Baseball
Federation and the "Major League Baseball"
announced a historic deal which could have
widespread diplomatic ramifications.
It's a good day for Cuban baseball, for world
baseball, for our people, for the American
people.
The agreement should be a home run for both
sides, as it provides Cubans with a safe,
regulated path to playing in the US while
compensating the Cuban Baseball Federation
for any players making the jump.
As it currently stands, Cuban players have
to defect and give up their citizenship for
a chance at making it in the majors, which
has led to criminal organizations trafficking
players.
Fans in Havana are pleased with the deal,
if not it's timing.
It's a step forward for the Cuban game.
It's something the Cuban state should have
done years ago, that's the reality of it.
But political relations could still put the
brakes on the deal.
Baseball was an important diplomatic tool
as then-US president Barack Obama sought to
normalize relations with Cuba, and he even
caught a game with Raúl Castro while visiting
Havana.
Tensions have reached a higher pitch under
Donald Trump, who has rolled back most of
the agreements made by his predescessor.
US politicans from Trump's Republican party
have already criticized the announced deal.